I feel just sick to my stomach, like I've
got food poisoning. That's how it happens
for me.
I would sort of see things. Your brain
would just distort things.
My obsession about
it changed everything... not for the better.
Hi, I'mTim. I'm 29 and I've been dealing with OCD for 21
years.
Director: When were you diagnosed
with the eating disorder?
When I was 24.
Mum said I was always a pretty anxious kid.
The anxiety was terrible. To keep people from
dying it would be flicking on light switches,
tapping feet, getting dressed and undressed.
It used to take me 45 minutes to get dressed.
It's a rabbit hole, you'll just get stuck. And
then you can't really move on until you feel
like that compulsion has been completed to your
mind's satisfaction.
They weren't sure. They
thought it might be ADHD at one stage but I think
they sort of came to the conclusion it was OCD.
My OCD thoughts turned to body image issues
when I was 21 years old.
The thoughts sort of
came around, I had my 21st with one of my best
mates and we got the photos back from that and
I just looked at the photos and I just didn't like what I saw.
There was comments about
my body and stuff like that. And I guess
cause of my obsessive nature, I kind of
became obsessed about sort of what was said.
Itspiralled pretty quickly.
In a six-month period,
it was noticeable that there something was
wrong. Having to go through the thoughts of
eating that meal, I just wouldn't get hungry.
And then there was other behaviours, there was
chuck food out when people weren t looking,
purging. My brother, he couldn't look at me
I think he ended up crying.
Going to ahospital, the psychiatrist kinda said:
"Yeah it's time to come in. Your organs
are starting to struggle."
The brain fog,
I'd just stand there. Trying
to do a crossword, good luck.
Read a book, good luck. All I could do is
probably lie down and sleep most of the time.
So I was in different clinics and different
day programs during a four year, five year
period.
I was the only male. The only male
in all of them. It was a very depressing,
a very lonely time. You can have as many
people around you. Your support network can be
as great as anything but it's
still a lonely lonely journey.
I started on my road to recovery when I
was 26. As you learn techniques to help
with your anxiety and you believe that you
want to get better, that's the main thing.
You have to want to get better. And I still
deal with it. It s not like you come out of a
clinic and you re 100% better. I'll probably
fight this for the rest of my life. I don't
think there's a cure for OCD. It's something
you manage. Someone explained it to me like
managing diabetes. I wasn't able to work a while,
for quite a number of years. But luckily now, I'm
in a healthier body so I currently work for a NDIS
company in Newcastle. I can't help other people
if I don't tell my experiences. That's the
main reason I want to speak out. So if there's
other men experiencing these issues, I can help
them. I get out most weekends playing golf. I'm
about to become an uncle so that's my
main priority now. And getting better.